mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
es ist ein bisschen sehr essentiell ist
ich mag glücklich wenn man kein zettel
zurück ich finde jeder party wartet
jahren geist
[Musik]
ich glaube ich bis jetzt zu viel geld
ist also toll will denn weil es mir
vorstelle was manchmal sei es hat auch
vorteile
gesundheit ist für die studien auge die
rohre sind gewisse nicht ums geld
verbunden mit armut
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
zeit ist geld das kind bin ich sehr spaß
angst als erwachsene versuche ist noch
ganz richtig viel ist nicht los am heck
das ende von monatlich
600 13 55 jetzt kennt sich man meinen
kontostand und vielleicht kennen sie ja
mich auch schon von instagram da bin ich
nämlich unterwegs bei sf kultur ich
verlange machen ihn am elvis brunner
sind pandemie bedingt ausgefallen und
darum bin ich heute da und da heißt im
bernischen historischen museum herzlich
willkommen bei kulturplatz
[Musik]
als ehemalige bankangestellte hatte ich
schon millionen in meinen händen ich
kenne mich also etwas aus in diesem
metier klar ist geld beeinflusst unser
leben man will es haben aber man will
nicht unbedingt darüber sprechen dieses
tabu lassen wir heute gekonnt hinter uns
wir fragen uns zuerst war es eigentlich
ist geld ganz genau mein kollege sieht
man welche antworten und zeigt auf ob
wir wirklich im zeitalter des
entfesselten geldes leben so wie diese
ausstellung hier behauptet
knete die kohle muss mäuse moneten
pulver peseten piepenstock
schottersteine geld hat viele namen doch
was genau ist es eigentlich zur
erklärung geht's ab und die bade
ausstellung mit dem co kurator hier kann
das publikum der museumsteam fragen
stellen also david diesel ihn ein schott
wirtschaftswissen bitte
klassisch wird egal wir sind die
funktionen definiere das war
zahlungsmittel wertaufbewahrungsmittel
und rache
einheitlich bezahlen begriff tun haben
wir jetzt für die umstellung da machen
der begriff gewalt wo heißt gallischer
bewegungs technologie was meinen wir mit
dem geld bewegt gestand ware geld bewegt
in zukunft mehr spart geld bewegt unsere
emotionen aus der fasste umfassenden
blick etwas galten sie geld bewegt seit
über 5000 jahren so alt ist die früheste
erhaltene quelle eine tontafel aus dem
heutigen irak dokumentiert das
tauschmittel die entfesselung nimmt
gemäss ausstellung ihren lauf ein erster
markanter schritt die erfindung der
münze im siebten jahrhundert vor
christus fortan ließ sich auf märkten
waren nicht bloß gegen ware tauschen
sondern auch gegen ein beglaubigtes mit
teilstück
dann und 1000 nach christus
das erste papier geld in china leichte
noten stadt schwerer münzen und somit
vereinfachte transaktionen
ein sprung in die jüngere vergangenheit
bis 1971 ist der us-dollar an den wert
des goldes gebunden nach der
entkoppelung von diesem knappen gut
flexibilisiert sich das gesamte
währungssystem
der jüngste schritt führt vom analogen
ins digitale zu crypto währungen wie
bitcoins gepriesen in werbe spots
[Musik]
stadtwehr bank erfolgter zahlungsverkehr
neu direkt vom sender zur empfängerin
geld so omnipräsent assist wird
zunehmend unfassbar
es ist das jüngste kapitel in der
geschichte der entfesselung
seit sich entkoppelt vom edelmetall
vertrag verändert das heißt sie mir sehr
stark in digitale in die mangel heute
gesehen dann galaform sind festlich und
es zeigt dabei unser emotion und total
entfesselte ihm galt gegner und ich
glaube der begriff entfesselt fast all
die dimensionen von galt mit dem begriff
zeigt sich auch die politik und
wirtschaft philosophin katja gentinetta
einverstanden
genauso wie mit der damit verbundenen
entwicklung die erweitere unseren
aktionsradius und
sich nur in
fortschrittlichen möglich dass wir
keine österreich ein händler dass wir
aber nimmer nur auf dem dorfplatz
energie und hat verbindungen und
umgekehrt sondern welche hinter mit dem
geld sache leisten wo irgendwo auf der
welt entwickelt und produziert worden
sind über den nutzen für altena von
jeder einzelnen transport das ist ganz
andere diskussion aber so möglich ist
ein lebensstandard und den wohlstand
also schlichtweg nicht möglich war
die entfesselung hat auch den kunstmarkt
erfasst ein treiber die inflation
anleger innen befürchten einen
werteverfall des geldes und halten nach
alternativen ausschau und überlege den
investitionen sind das immobilie ist
habe alle kunst und die kunst mit ganz
speziellen spezielle markt will ich und
du will die wilde ist die weste vor
allem mehr unreguliert da ich ihnen
transparent ist global und das macht man
sich genauso faszinierend großartig und
interessant das konnte zweimal so
zweiten dann zu sehr für extrem viel
geld in der kunst martine first und das
studentische priester für die kunststadt
kommunen in den medien gehört so werfen
gar werke hohe preise ab die das system
kritisieren dieses bild von banksy hätte
sich nach der auktion selbst schreddern
sollen und erhöhte genau dadurch seinen
wert welche
die verquickung von kunst und kapital
oft hinterfragt obwohl kulturschaffende
gerade davon leben etwa durch andy
warhols dollar bills
joseph beuys ausstellung kapital
oder hans peter feldmanns hunderttausend
dollar gewinnt an die museumswand
ich find so spekulationen
frage wie man das künstliche umsätze
finde ich sehr interessant
muss aber feststellen dass sie sehr oft
nur sehr wirtschafts kritische sicht
kommen die müssen als solche laster mit
der müssen sich als soll befassen aber
ich war trotzdem immer wieder darauf
verwiesen
was für eine möglichkeit
kalt ich gar zum wachsen zum besser
klappe
standen künstler einst dem sold von
klerus oder adel ist der markt heute
viel größer und damit die konkurrenz
der trendy sein will kreiert werke die
es nur als digitale datei gibt mit
diesen sogenannten nfc es hat sich auch
die kunst entfesselt
[Musik]
bezahlt wird sie immer öfter in kripp
bewährung das passt crypto kunst und
crypto währung werden gehandelt als
spekulationsobjekte kunst und
künstlichkeit in kombination
cryptome geheißen ja nicht umsonst
cryptome gewinns kryptisch sind aber es
ist ganz verwirrt und ich stehe es mich
verstand mit ganz genau was da wirklich
passiert und wir das passiert wahrlich
wird so es eigentlich nur wenn man sich
zu viel obwohl nächsten vorgestellt die
welt kranker aus den fugen geraten wenn
unwissen auf profit sucht stößt auf
habgier kriminelle machenschaften oder
fehlerhafte marktanalysen wie bei der
immobilienkrise in den usa mit der
pleite der investmentbank lehman
brothers 2008
sie kostete ganze existenzen zur auf
es geht bald systemen vertraut und alles
live die rationalisierte dann geht es ab
und extras und ihrer nationalität vor
sie hoffe nicht um alle wünsche dem
galten sind und hier zwei sachen sind
spiegler verstärkte mensch
ob wir nun den kapitalismus hoch halten
oder ihn überwinden wollen geld diese
menschliche erfindung ist ausdruck
unserer persönlichkeit und so entfesselt
dass es unser denken handeln und sein
geradezu fesselt
nico seine sie sind co kuratorin der
ausstellung was ist steht teil wo sie am
allermeisten interessierten geld will
aspekt
ziemlich langweilig wird es spannend
fans mit menschen zusammen und um geld
wird
also galt als kulturgut wo wirklich alle
lebensbereiche ihnen fließt und glaube
das macht der komplex wir seit ganz
unterschiedlichen staatlichen
habe der chrome in cancer bin immer
folgenlos haben dieses interessante
seite das geld an sich eigentlich kein
wert und ich habe mit ihnen bedeutet
warum vertrau mir den dem geld trotzdem
was würden sie sagen ist natürlich im
alltag benutzen wir halt und bericht in
der schweiz funktioniert also beruf
verlor dass man mir mit dem garten
kosten oder mit dem handy abos über
wiese dass die bezahlung funktioniert
und ich glaube
das vertrauen
das mir nicht also ich mach mir überlegt
mir nicht am morgen einige stoffe
traurig
sondern ich bin jetzt das geld will die
alltag mehr als babys das geld
funktioniert in youtube in konstanz
webseite eine kleine sitze ausbauen
minute
würde sie mir ihre kunden stand auswege
stellen vorhanden
wie es doch
bis über ein verortet
wird man vielleicht geordnet wird wenn
der vergleich wird muss flottesten das
verrottete wäre sparsamen später viel
ausgeben und wie
gut die frage nicht ganz bewusst aus
weil die frage was er sparsam
also ist wichtig dass sie bis auf der
hohen kante
warum hat mir den so hemker zum beispiel
das geld rede ich glaubte mich ist
wirklich so wie es halt sehr schnell
wird persönlich wird und sehr viel
themen uns im labor spricht wo
überall die werte wurden bei
diskussionen es entsteht und finden sie
denn dass mir zu wenig über geld reden
ich glaube ich persönliche rede ich
relativ weniger begabt ich bitte meine
ich nach allem was wird sich verändern
wenn wir über geld reden ich glaub mir
würde vielleicht woanders
es ist liebe gestaltet und mir würde es
vielleicht nie gedanken machen wir alles
zusammen hat
und dass man wieder offen ihre blicke
und soll ist immer gut mit bin und was
ich schon sehr relevant finden ist kalte
staatlichen routiniers also bei
metalist aber wenn es galt hand ist
routine ich gebe es zu ich habe lag
nicht viel was wir machen und sie so
ausgeprägt und ich denke dass nie
verkehrt die sache wo mehr routinemäßig
möchte schritt zurück zu machen
reflektieren
das mache ich
danke
in der ausstellung spielt auch der
berner rapper tommy berset die eine
wichtige rolle er kommt hier eine
gesprächsreihe university forscht dazu
wie geld in den medien und in werbung
dargestellt wird und er sagt und das
finde ich ziemlich interessant diese
darstellung die brauche es damit wir
immer weiter an die idee des geldes
glauben
er ist eine prägende figur in der
schweizer rapper szene
university seine texte derb und direkt
streitbar auch
[Musik]
er übt harsche kritik an der
gesellschaft am geld und seinen zwängen
[Gelächter]
der schnöde mammon beschäftigt ihn nicht
nur in der musik
der recker doktoriert an der hochschule
der künste bern über die darstellung des
geldes in massenmedialen bildern
stützt
und das ist ja auch gar nichts von dem
moment wo sie sagen die
ästhetik visuell ist auch
ein vorbild krieger vorwürfe
die stuttgart die die diebe gläubiger
das geld ist eine erfindung des menschen
und muss als solche immer wieder
legitimiert werden sagt der city in
einem teil seiner studien vergleich der
bildwelten von rap plattencovern mit
banken werbung
tepco will sich auf bank aval weg aber
eigentlich sowie große dass das kind
betreut risch
das ist eigentlich nicht wahnsinnig groß
also sich sowieso faszinierend wie viel
motiv und wie viel
prestige objekte der bank habe der akku
sehr ähnlich ist
das auch
das hat doch immerhin noch eine art
best brand in seinen texten das
kapitalistische system und die macht des
geldes an
[Musik]
einziehen kann er sich dem geld denken
nicht aber sich bewusst damit
beschäftigen er analysiert mit klarer
haltung die soziale ungerechtigkeit in
der gesellschaft
[Musik]
wütende texte rap das war schon immer
die musik der nicht privilegierten auto
megacity alias simon küffer ist
bescheiden aufgewachsen sein vater war
lange arbeitslos er selber machte seine
lehre bei einer firma die konkurs ging
er wurde grafiker und lebte von der hand
in den mund
klappt es
das
ist was
die tüftelt zurzeit mit rapper kollege
mario an neuen stücken
2010 brachte er sein erstes soloalbum
heraus 2009 10 sein zweites
erfolgreich ist er reicht nicht
macht es vor
es ist ja die sicherheitsfrage macht
ohne zwang und macht storniert und macht
storni bevor nun die
geldnot macht abhängig und erzeugt
unerträgliche zwänge ein wichtiges thema
auf als zweitem album
da kommen auch aktiv mit diensten mutter
sie markiert
sozialkritik die auch seine forschung
trägt das ist schöner hier oder snoop
dogg kosovo in der hinterhand hätte der
bullen
und ich nicht so die ganz direkt
bestellt also geschafft die frau oder
sechst oder so immer
und da immer der typ wo das recht selbst
liter ist jeder großen stadt mit glas
brandy wie mir die augen zumachen
nachmittag und hier original botero alle
schlussendlich ist es
preislich geschichte
aber um 40 jahren nach oder durch sowie
die gleiche also quasi respekt wie es
weiter
hieß haben sind eben deswegen aber dir
gar keine bestell ich schon hier alles
geht der hat sie ganz grausam und brutal
ist szene darstellt also da irgendwie
gebaut
umweltzerstörung bereits zum ball und
tor symbol noten etc die schleuniger
olympischer liegt hier das quasi das
bildnis
etwas kaltes fruchtbar oder soziale
konten der bank oder banken hin ich habe
wieder was los ist und hier der
begangenen wachsen musste aber wirklich
wieder also hier die person eines
toasters
dabei bis zehn menschen begleiten suisse
oder das breite portfolio oder so immer
einer
gegenfrage nötige investitionen und
redner aber genau das hier hervor
wenn das geld derartig problem behaftet
ist
was wäre denn die alternative
muss jetzt carlitos
die damen sind aber auch öffentliches
gut behandelt also bis man demokratisch
reifer haben sowieso analytik
jena und nicht als naturgewalt woody
allen da ausländer hervorbringt und
diese großteils
massiv die
regierte fühlen
[Musik]
tommy varsity das geld treibt ihn um
eine radikale systemkritik die uns den
spiegel vorhält
am zwanzigsten februar ist university
übrigens zu gast in der s11 sternstunde
religion unter dem titel marx moneten
und maria magdalena
[Musik]
liga doch
die größte bedeutung
von 1700 hinterlässt wegen seine kriege
einen bankrotten französischen staates
werden
[Musik]
in münster inzwischen die große wünsche
angenommen sie wissen sie werden mal
viele viele millionen erben was tun sie
sich freuen weniger arbeiten die
österreicherin marlene englischhorn hat
sich entschieden ihr vermögen zu
verschenken 90 prozent davon meine
kollegin melissa varela von instagram sf
kultur hat sie getroffen in berlin
engelhorn ich werde einmal einen
zweistelligen millionenbetrag erben und
ich halte das für rasend ungerecht denn
marlene engelhorn ihre familie hat in
der mitte vom neunzehnte jahrhundert der
heutige pharmakonzern basf gründet das
vermögen der familie wird es bei 4,2
milliarden geschätzt aber wie viel von
denen pläne genauer und macht sie uns
netzwerk halterner ich bin isa varela
mehr mit 21 jährige machen die inhalte
geredet was sie so sehr am thema erbe
stört und wieso sie ihres ganze vermögen
weil vermögen in dieser größenordnung
keine privatsache mehr sind sondern da
geht es um das was alle berührt nämlich
wie wir mit vermögen grundsätzlich
umgehen und mit ungleichheit und
deswegen möchte ich mindestens 90
prozent je nachdem wie viel das dann
wird auch mehr um verteilen lassen
marlene sei dass sie durch die richtung
vor eine ältere islam privilegiert sie
sich aber erst an der uni sich den
privilegien wirklich bewusst wurde ich
dort hat das begonnen andere
lebensrealitäten zu zu verstehen weil es
dann nicht so eine sache ist von wegen
jahren macht einen studentenjob neben
der uni weil es irgendwie cool ist
sondern macht es wenn man muss weil es
anders nicht geht und dann gibt es
vielleicht eine person die sich
ernsthaft überlegen muss her kann ich
mir einen spontanen café leisten oder
nicht oder beginnt plötzlich zu
verstehen dass die eigene
selbstverständlichkeit dass ich überall
rein gehen kann so viel kaffee kaufen
wie ich lustig bin dass das nicht allen
so geht und weil sie das insekt hält
sich gern an vermögen reicher freue also
sauer weil das mit
gerechtigkeit vorstellungen die ich habe
überhaupt nicht zusammenpasst und für
mich hat sich daraus der konflikte geben
gut wenn ich die eine politische
vorstellung habe dann muss ich aber auch
in meinem politischen handeln konsequent
das miteinander verknüpfen und in meinen
augen geht es einfach nicht wenn man auf
den millionen sitzen bleibt sondern muss
auch dann fair sein und sagen ich habe
dafür nichts gemacht du hast vielleicht
macht auf die familie oder man wird in
der regel nicht superreich durch arbeit
dafür braucht es mehrere generationen
ich glaube bis zu sieben generationen
kann es brauchen um aus der armut klasse
in die sogenannte mittelschicht
aufzusteigen das heißt vermögen und
arbeit gehen nicht linear zusammen der
chef von red bull so er didi mateschitz
wenn man sein vermögen her nimmt dann
müsste ein österreicher
durchschnittsösterreicher
österreicherin
700.000 jahre lang nichts anderes machen
als zu arbeiten und zu sparen der
schläft nicht der ist nicht gar nichts
der wohnt nicht hat keine miete gar nix
arbeiten und sparen
700.000 jahre ist die thematische
700.000 mal fleißiger ich würde es doch
bezweifelt marlene seit artist
ungerechtigkeit und armut das dir ihre
neben der karriere vor wo erste mal
gesund oder wieviel dass das genau ich
im gegensatz zum normalverdienende wenn
wir einerseits einverstanden sind damit
dass es menschen gibt die sich vor dem
amt komplett ausziehen müssen die alles
sagen müssen was sie besitzen bis auf
den letzten rappen müssen die alles
hergeben und zeigen und offen legen
warum bei denen warum ist es bei denen
in ordnung und bei reichen menschen
nicht warum müssen die nicht sagen wie
viele unternehmen wert ist oder wie viel
hier familienbesitz wert ist oder das
schloss wie viel das wert ist und wieso
wird da diese ausnahme gemacht wieso
darf da die privatsphäre geschützt
werden und das ist heilig und bei den
menschen die eh nix haben denen man
alles neidisch ist und die zweite
zahnbürste ihnen nicht vergönnt 30
plötzlich keine heilige privatsphäre wer
ist dann grundsätzlich marlene
auswärtstätigkeit sie will das vermögen
die nächste überzahl linien es geht ja
nicht darum irgend etwas wegzunehmen der
superreiche sondern im gegenteil es geht
darum dass superreiche der gesellschaft
nichts wegnehmen dürfen weil das ist das
was gerade passiert
da mache ich nicht gern mit ich möchte
gerne teilen radikal teilen so gut ich
kann iris manner spannung funde was man
in excited vor allem dabei was ich seit
das mannschaftsgefühl familie so riesch
will sich so hat es geschafft haben aber
es meistens er damit duell dass sie doch
irgendwelche äußere umstand extrem
privilegiert sie sind können wir uns
leisten dass alle so erben und so leben
wahrscheinlich nicht glaube dass es in
meinem absoluten interesse ist in einer
gesellschaft zu leben in der es allen
gut geht weil das schließt mich ein ich
hoffe hier noch an meinem crypto
paletten und denke noch ein wenig nach
über das wesen des geldes was denken sie
was kann man nicht mit geld kaufen
schreiben sie mir auf instagram auf sf
kultur nächste woche ist eva
wannenmacher wie die physiker dann von
den solothurner filmtagen jetzt gleich
gehts ums impfen in der debatte in der
sf sternstunde philosophie ich wünsche
ihnen eine gute zeit es baut
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos